our golf games are a little bit better
so
you know we'll see we'll see i do think
you do have a partner that would
probably have liked to go for a little
more often than he has in the past so
bryce i'm glad you're encouraging him to
to kind of go for it when it's on the
line so rather than
you know just knock into the fairway or
something like that and try to try to
play for the next shot yeah i i'll never
i'll never push anyone to do anything so
he can choose whatever he wants to do
all right well i usually don't get the
option in my
that's what i mean
you'll finally have the option
tom brady having a little fun with aaron
rodgers and that was bryson d chambeau
and phil mickelson they're playing golf
on july the 6th
brady has been
poking at that
bear to go for it on fourth down
the delivery wasn't awesome yesterday
anytime you have to say it twice for the
joke to land
you probably didn't make it land the
first time but aaron was great with his
comment about it he's said his piece in
the past
knows that he would just as soon have
gone for it he doesn't know why they
didn't go for it i don't know why they
didn't go for it tom brady doesn't know
why they didn't go for it but
uh maybe they'll get a chance to get
together again this year and and the
package this time this time on fourth
down good morning chris how are you i'm
doing good man uh good to see you yeah i
mean it's cool to see that nonetheless i
do love seeing brady in that like way
where he's joking around and doing stuff
like that yeah it wasn't his best
delivery
i got a question for you yeah
are you conflicted when your favorite
player of all time
is on one side of the screen and a guy
of whom you're so jealous is right next
to him i know i'm very jealous that's
hard it's really tough i know isn't it
funny that's what everybody thinks i am
i'm just that's what they boiled it down
to that is the laziest 15 year old
reaction any criticism you're just
jealous get out of here with that crap
yeah i know to borrow your phrase thank
you thank you very much way to use it
it's properly properly used there but
it is cool that that brady does do that
and i think what's good about it too is
he knows it's not like
a personal thing right so there's it's a
good way to do it he knows that wasn't
roger's decision that was the packers it
was matt lefleur he's ultimately the guy
there that made that decision so it's
good to poke fun at it he won the super
bowl and i i am going to tune in to
watch this i mean i watched it last year
and i think this might even be a little
more spicier to me with rogers and and
uh the d shambo kind of combination
there
and we have to give credit for the joke
where credit is due
whoever brady pays
to do social media media came up with it
right brady just co-opted it like
they're his writers right and he sees
what works and maybe he'll try some of
it out when it's an opportunity for him
to to do a video conference like he did
yesterday to promote the match coming up
on yeah july 6th straight so but okay i
was gonna say go ahead all right i mean
let's get to the other elephant in the
room there um yes why was he wearing a
t-shirt that said i'm offended
what was that for what do you think like
in your heart of hearts you know in your
heart of hearts why do you think aaron
rodgers is wearing a t-shirt that says
i'm offended
well you know it's funny because when i
first saw the video i didn't realize it
was a mad emoji under it i thought it
was tweety bird are you familiar with
tweety brother i do yes i'm i'm old
enough to remember that yes
and and i became very curious
about whether anything was written under
i'm offended
because it it just the way i look at
that the way it's it's
structured i feel like there's something
written under
the the mean bug emoji
i'm just curious what else is on the
shirt i know well maybe it says i'm
offended mark murphy maybe that's what
it says on the bottom
that's what we can't see i'm offended
and complicated right wouldn't that be
awesome that would be awesome
but the way that guy works and not that
we like really know him personally or
anything it's like it just seems like he
wore that intentionally he's smart it's
like everything you've ever said you
know he's calculated he's snarky he's
got all the traits and i don't know i
just found that kind of amusing that he
wore that i mean you could take it i
want to take it a step farther though
right did he like stay up late
one night over the weekend ordering it
on etsy or ebay or somewhere so he'd
have it in time for this event on
tuesday i i don't doubt that either i
don't i think i think he is you know
he's got a fedex account he can get next
day shipment and get that done so i
don't doubt that either i think that was
uh
nice and intentionally planned and like
a good little just a good little shot
there that's kind of like you know might
not go noticed by a lot of people
i just love to think that these guys are
like the rest of us when it comes to
things like that like checking his phone
refreshing the update with the tracking
number to see if it was released for
shipment and sent to the facility and
what time do i think it's going to show
up and peeking through the curtains to
see if the white trucks coming up the
hill i wonder if he was like hey i got
to get that shirt oh i got to get that
shirt i need that i'm gonna get here by
ten o'clock i gotta get that shirt i i i
just i i i i'm sure at some level they
are normal i don't know at what level
they're normal but at some level they're
normal yeah no they are normal and i
think they're all a little bit more
petty than we all think we think they
are listen i i worked for i lived with a
a really good quarterback maybe not of
the level of aaron rodgers and tom brady
i could tell you yeah he's just like a
lot of the other people on this planet
he is there's no doubt about it so yes
and uh
you know i don't know it'd be tough for
you what do you do when you got like a
fedex delivery and you're looking for it
you got to walk all the way down your
mountain to get down there to look for
the car we have a road oh we have a road
i didn't know i thought you had a gate
at the bottom they weren't allowed up
until you see or you just watch them on
your camera and that's how you know they
go oh i'm with chateau florio let me see
turn the camera on to see him coming up
you don't need a gate at the bottom when
you got a shotgun at the top first of
all
second
second they just drive right up they
drive right up all right and and i have
a dog that dog hears the truck five
miles away yeah right i bet as soon as
the final approach up the hill is made
the dog starts barking and barking and
and so we know that that that there's a
delivery right but yeah we have cameras
and other security devices yeah with a
shotgun i like that i want to put that
in my driveway like on a plaque right
there you know gate at the bottom
shotgun at the top come in
they probably think you do have a
shotgun with the chickens and the they
probably your
dogs and the whatever other animals you
got running around there yeah all right
uh aaron rodgers also was asked
a question
that was very sarcastic in tone and
content
but he gave a straight answer to it it
was really strange let's let's listen to
the question from the host whose name
escapes me
his initials are ba i know that because
rogers repeats them but uh the question
and then the answer from rogers as it
relates to this eventful offseason that
he's been experiencing
you've really
kept a low profile this offseason i've
hardly seen your name at all you haven't
hosted any tv shows or been in and
involved in any kind of controversy or
anything it's been a nice peaceful
offseason for you it sounds like ar it's
been yes thank you ba it's been one of
those quiet offseasons you just dream
about where you can just kind of go
through your process on your own quietly
and
um you know that's all you can ask for
as an older player in the league and
someone who's been around for a long
time and just enjoys that time to
yourself just relax and not be bothered
to not have any obligations or anything
going on
you know i think that's what this off
season's been about it's been about
really enjoying my time and spending it
where i want to spend it and not feeling
like i have to go anywhere not having
any responsibilities but still being an
nfl player at the same time it's been
great
ba was brian anderson brian anderson
brian anderson and and
it was just so odd that he was trying to
set him up
with that sarcasm
and there was this
very
matter-of-fact
unironic response from rogers saying hey
yeah oh and
oh i just wanted an offseason without
obligations like that's all it is all
this stuff that's gone on since the the
fuse was lit right after the loss of the
buccaneers in the nfc championship game
and the bomb exploded on the first day
of the draft
there's nothing to it at all i just
wanted to have an off season with no
obligations well he did have one
obligation last week i would consider a
mandatory mini camp an obligation right
so the the whole answer was weird to me
and it makes me think he really is
setting up
a return
and
and then he'll act like
what's the big deal what's everybody
looking at i don't get it what's what's
wrong i'm here to play football i i had
a quiet offseason i had no obligations
and now i'm here and now i'm back and
i'm an nfl player again he mentioned
that about being an nfl player didn't
say he's gonna play for the packers
right but i think he's i think he's
preserving that ability
to just show up at the first day of
training camp and act like everything
was fine
i i don't doubt that i think that's
gonna be his move ultimately you know
not that like everything's fine but yeah
i don't think he's gonna like address
this and just open up the vault and just
let us all know his heart and everything
that went on this offseason i don't know
he's probably gonna play coy like
continue to act like yeah it wasn't
quite as big a deal as it was and all of
those type of things uh there's no doubt
listen i don't know i mean you you look
at that right there with that clip and
everything he said there you know he's
trying not to hijack the tournament i
think to a degree and not make it all
about him and his offseason and all that
and make headlines there so i do
understand that to a degree but like i
you know i've seen this clip now three
times
and like there's one thing i notice
every time when he gets asked the
question he's kind of grinning brady's
laughing it's almost he loves it i love
it he loves it it's like ba told him and
brian anderson's a great dude like hey
i'm going to ask you this question and
like they almost joked about it before
they did this and like you know that's
where and you know even the way rogers
answers it goes yeah yeah thanks b.a i
appreciate that like i felt like that
was kind of sarcastic where he was like
yeah thanks for that question we all
know the obvious answer yeah thanks for
bringing that up exactly you know so i i
do i felt like there was there was
something there and yeah he
intentionally avoided you know the meat
and potatoes part of that conversation
whether it's the sake of he just doesn't
want to deal with it or maybe he just
wants to keep this to the match and and
not take away from that
and and i guess brian anderson had to
ask the question yeah right not ask the
question
but
i just the the answer sets up what we
ultimately could get if he can't find a
way out of this maze that allows him
to get whatever it is that he wants and
we still don't know what he wants
because number one he won't tell us and
number two the people to whom he's told
what he wants like james jones will tell
us anything and everything but
what aaron rodgers wants the beautiful
mystery continues concocted in large
part by aaron rodgers and i guarantee
you chris
he he is giving us a prime example of a
dynamic that i've pointed to in the past
everybody look at me
what the hell are you looking at he
wants everybody to talk about him and he
wants to reserve the right to be pissed
off that people are spending all this
time talking about him i think he loves
it and and whether he loves it or not i
just think that he can't avoid creating
this situation it just it's just
it's just happened and and there's an
element of normal human being in that as
well
that
you know not all of us have the
opportunity to to be in that situation
where we can create so much attention
and then resent the attention we've
created but i feel like that's what he's
doing not to psychoanalyze him but i
really feel like there's an element of
that to this i i do too i don't i don't
you know deny that and you know i love
aaron rodgers i mean yeah he's my
favorite and everything like that but no
i i think you're real with that like
read on him a little bit as a person you
know not you know again not that i know
him that well i mean i only i walked
down the fairway with him twice in my
life okay uh during when i was out in
lake tahoe it's only time i've really
ever talked to aaron rodgers so that's
where
you know yeah i agree with you from all
these years of watching him and doing uh
and interviews and things like that but
at the same time you know it is a tough
situation
um yes
he did create a a situation here but he
didn't really create it he's created the
current situation of why we're talking
about it because it was it was the
result of another situation created by
green bay so yeah he had to let like
some of his thoughts be known as far as
maybe wanting to be traded like we've
heard and all of those type of things to
get out of a situation that he's not
happy with you know so now yeah he's
never going to give us like the press
conference real answers that we want
we're never going to know you know his
tactical reasons behind some of these
things no he's not and he's going to
give us bland answers like you're saying
it's going to make it sound like
we were a little too crazy to read into
that you know that's that is the way i
think he'll play it but i can't fault
him for it either
maybe he could approach it a little
differently during training camp but but
i don't fault him for this situation
he's in and it's a tough situation to
handle for sure
matt casey just mentioned something that
we have to look forward to yeah i don't
know within the next five or ten years
the aaron rodgers
memoirs the
yeah right rogers spin
on everything that's happened who will
write it with him he'll probably write
it himself he's smart enough to do it
the content will be very interesting and
uh maybe i'll get an advanced copy so i
can say to all of you don't waste your
time
reading that crap that would be the
ultimate turnabout you know he's made it
clear though when he's done playing
football he's not going to be involved
in broadcasting i don't know what he's
going to do we know about the jeopardy
stuff and the executive producer of
jeopardy thinks that he can have an even
better post-football career than he had
as a football career which is a pretty
high bar but
he's said multiple times that he just he
doesn't want to be involved in
broadcasting football which you know if
tony romo is getting a million bucks a
game
yeah i'd like to think aaron rodgers
could walk right through the door and
get a million bucks a game yeah i mean
that'll that'll always be there right i
mean for guys like him i mean peyton
manning aaron rodgers i mean the second
they say they want to do that networks
are going to go what okay yep let me see
if we could figure out you know
something to to get you on here i mean
yeah but he does not seem that to be
that type of guy you're right he's got
other interests i mean you know he's he
travels around the world he certainly
seems to be
you know a little bit more diverse maybe
than your your typical quarterback as
far as that stuff is concerned and yeah
i could see him totally stepping away
he's just not i don't know i just don't
see him being the type of guy that's
going to dissect things for people on tv
and want to be a part of all that stuff
he's gotten all in on football for a
long time and when it's over for playing
he's he's done
well one thing he hasn't been doing
during this quiet off season is eating
excessive amounts of food
he still looks skinny yeah better that
picture again
when when do you have to get the suit of
of armor right the flesh armor on your
midsection so you're able to withstand
the pounding that you're going to take
as a 37 year old quarterback in the nfl
i would think that's got to start here
like pretty soon you know as far as yeah
you know putting putting that armor on
like you're talking about you know again
getting
getting in the weight room working out
building that structure not only for
like the armor you're talking about but
again this is a guy that does still
depend on his movement and being
explosive and trying to you know get out
of the pocket from time to time and make
those throws so
yeah it's definitely something i'll be
watching because he's been skinny in
every video we've shown and you know me
i'm always about the legs and the butt
and those type of things to me that was
a huge difference of what i saw from
rogers in 2020 to 2019 and i think
you've heard me say that in 2019 i
thought oh maybe he's lost a little bit
of a step and if you go back and look at
him at that time he got into like he
wanted to be the brady yoga i'm going to
try to do all that stuff his pants
didn't even fit him like he really
didn't they barely went over his ass if
you really watch it last year it looked
different it did and his play was
different so you know as a fan of him
i'm going okay let's go let's get in the
weight room here we go
because he's not tom brady explosive
movements are more a part of his game
and he can't just be doing yoga and
eating avocado ice cream all the time
that's not the way he plays
did you catch the comment that he made
when he was messing around with phil
mickelson talking about intimidating
phil
with his calf muscles and he said that
the muscle that he injured the leg that
he injured doesn't look the same as the
other one i mean i've pulled a calf
muscle and it looks the same he must
have had a pretty serious injury maybe
it's from when in dominicans who stomped
on his leg but isn't that odd to think
he's got one calf muscle that looks
different than the other well it is odd
yeah i mean you don't see that very
often he's had he's had a what i mean
how many times has he had problem with
that calf muscle i'm gonna say it's been
at least three times right in his career
so it could be at the point where yeah
if you've stretched that connection
point where that calf inserts there that
you can damage it enough to where it
starts to look different like i've done
that you know not that i'm aaron rodgers
but my bicep tendon you know like i kind
of pulled that i tore that it never kind
of looks the same it's i got like a hole
in my right bicep so that does happen
with those kind of injuries uh yeah a
little odd but yeah he's a high-end
athlete and he can't just be like hey
i'm just gonna sit here and throw and
you know be skinny and and not explosive
and do those type of things or his game
is gonna fall off in a big way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports